je reviens de vacances c'est la raison
pour laquelle après un long voyage j'ai
à la fois une mine radieuse apport au
bronzage est une mine de merde rapport
au jet lag du coup c'est marrant très
effacé ma rentrée
jour 2 parce que j'ai déjà commencé à
tourner hier et pour ma rentrée quoi de
mieux après m'être fait dorer la peau au
soleil tout l'été que de me faire dorer
la peau du cul au laser pour la dix
neuvième séance à la 11e avec avec cette
technique l'a donc comme d'habitude mon
fils et on en parle après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà qui a terminé donc occupé comme
promis et comme d'habitude maintenant
petit petit débrief donc d'abord je me
suis planté
c'est pas du tout la dix neuvième séance
c'est la dix huitième séance 7 dans
l'ancien centre 11 dans ce centre là
voilà c'est mérité d'être précisés donc
dix huitième séance mêmes réglages que
les dernières fois maintenant à priori
on est parti sur ce rythme de croisière
là jusqu'à la fin donc un truc qui qui
bastonne un peu avec des réglages un peu
intermédiaire entre le cul switch et le
pico jours mais bon quand même avec la
technologie optique au chaud à écouter
on verra ça à la fin mais le médecin est
à la fois satisfait de l'évolution parce
que je spoile pas mais avoue que c'est
pas mal
et en même temps hambourg ma comme ça
sera difficile de le nier mais
effectivement il trouve que c'est un
petit peu l'eau alors manifestement
c'est habituel que sur la fin ça traîne
un peu en longueur qui le l'interlock
est selon lui la raison pour laquelle ça
prend autant de temps c'est que des
endroits où visuellement on a
l'impression qu'il ya plus ou plus
beaucoup de pigments mais quand même
quand ils passent le laser dessus ça
crépite ce qui veut dire que là le
pigment un pet donc ça veut dire qu'il y
en a donc il reste a priori du pigment
planqué profond donc donc ça ça traîne
en longueur ça c'est pour les endroits
où il reste
il reste est très visible il ya des
endroits où il n'en sait pour les
endroits où il reste des très peu
visible et pour les endroits où il reste
des très visible parce que vous verrez
qu'il y en a quand même c'est simplement
qu'il ya une grosse dose de pigments et
qu'il faut il faut continuer à y aller
donc on continue à y aller mais bon vous
vous verrez à la fin
alors avant de voir tout ça je voudrais
revenir sur un petit point sur une
question qu'on me pose très souvent j'en
ai déjà un peu parlé mais je me disais
que bah c'était pas mal de faire le
petit point un peu un peu précis
là-dessus aujourd'hui c'est la douleur
voilà très très nombreux encore même
quand je croise des gens à me dire mais
au fait où ça fait mal c'est quoi le
alors pour être très clair je dirais
mais c'est bon la douleur de toute façon
c'est hyper subjectif c'est ça dépend
vraiment beaucoup de la personne qu'ils
leur sang est la façon dont elle
recentre son rapport à la douleur de sa
tolérance machin etc
donc je peux comme d'habitude évidemment
parler que de mon cas personnel mais je
dirais qu'en termes d'intensité par
rapport aux tatouages pour les gens qui
ont été tatoué sur la zone sur laquelle
j'ai été tatoué en termes de douleur tu
multiplies facile par dix
faire que lasers et environ 10 fois plus
douloureux que le tatouage
ça peut ça peut donner une idée sur la
sensation va d'abord il faut déjà bien
séparer les choses
j'ai eu de cette séance de cul switch
donc il est réputé un laser plus
douloureux que le pic au jour cette
séance sans crème anesthésiante et 11
séances avec crème anesthésiante sur le
sur le pic au chaud pour les séances
sans crème anesthésiante si je devais
comparer ça à une douleur que j'ai
jamais subi grand bien lui fasse
je dirais que ça ressemble très
probablement à ce qu'on doit ressentir
quand on te passe une lame de bistouri
par exemple chauffer à blanc à la flamme
d'un briquet c'est à dire que ça pique
slash ça à la coupe et en même temps ça
brûle voilà parce que le plus riche qui
est connu pour être très avoir des
effets thermiques important donc voilà
d'imaginer vous ça vous passez sur le
trait de votre tatouage une lame chauffé
à blanc voilà à peu près voilà moi c'est
bon c'est la façon dont je décrivais à
la chose ensuite ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que ce qui fait mal donc il ya un
l'effet thermique comme j'aime le dire
ça brûle c'est la lumière c'est de la
lumière pulsée voilà sur un faisceau
très précis donc ça brûle surtout le cul
switch qui est beaucoup moins le pico
sûr et il ya en plus de cet effet
thermique un effet mécanique qui est le
pigment quand il se fragmente quand il
explose si vous voulez sous la peau sous
l'effet du laser et ben ça fait mal
aussi
du coup si vous voulez vous faire une
idée auditive cette fois et pas à
sensorielle dites vous que plus on
entend les petits crépitements
du pigment qui explose quand on veut on
voit le laser passent et plus on entend
ces bruits la pluie ils sont forts plus
ça fait mal moi c'est un truc que j'ai
expérimenté vraiment
la sueur de mon cul alors je vais vous
faire un petit multiples démonstrations
écouter ça c'est le son de ma séance du
jour quelques voulait déjà entendu
[Musique]
et ça c'est le son d'une de mes
premières séances de qi swift
donc vous voyez que c'est pas la même
intensité de bruit maintenant voilà le
son avec l'image de ma séance du jour
et ça c'est le son avec l'image de la
séance de qi switch une des premières
donc voilà voyez qu au niveau du faciès
on se rend bien compte que c'est pas là
c'est pas la même douleur donc plus ça
fait du bruit plus ça fait mal en gros
maintenant évidemment aujourd'hui il ya
de moins en moins de pigments donc ça
explose de moins en moins donc ça fait
de moins en moins la halle il ya de
moins d'effets thermique avec le pic au
chu york avec le cul switch donc ça
brûle moins et puis surtout il ya la
preuve à la décision à ce sujet pour ma
prochaine séance je vais faire une
petite expérience j'ai jamais eu une
séance de pick au chaud sans crème
anesthésiante mais la prochaine fois je
vais faire sans voilà pour voir si
vraiment là c'est une douleur
différentes alors évidemment ce sera pas
complètement comparable mais je pourrais
avoir vraiment si effectivement comme on
l'a vendu ça brûle moins un que quelques
switch donc la prochaine fois je ferai à
sec sans point la liste eh bien voilà
donc en attendant cette prochaine séance
qui sera début novembre puisque là on
attend de nouveau deux mois étant donné
les réglages qui ont été faits sur la
sur la machine en attendant ça va le
reveal
le moment tant attendu donc voila comme
comme à l'accoutumée la photo de mon
tatouage avant la séance précédente
c'est-à-dire il ya maintenant deux mois
avant avant l'été et voilà la photo de
mon tatouage ce matin juste avant la
séance du jour donc vous voyez que comme
je voulais dit ça se passe ça se passe
plutôt pas mal les progrès se font se
font sentir et se et se voit c'est
toujours particulier c'est très bizarre
pour avec je vais essayer de réfléchir à
un moyen de contourner ça mais les
photos rendent vraiment pas du tout
la même impression que quand on voit ça
à l'oeil nu
je pense que c'est une histoire de
lumière qui se réfléchit etc déclare je
vais essayer de modifier sa pour pour
une des prochaines fois mais vous voyez
en tout cas que ça progresse
alors un petit truc marrant dont je me
suis souvenu c'est que là manifestement
il ya quand même des endroits où sa part
beaucoup mieux que d'autres
voyez là ici on voit plus rien là ici on
voit qu'il ya plus d'encre apparente en
tout cas mais bon bah on voit le
stigmate du laser qui passent là ici on
voit qu'il reste un petit peu de
pigments mais que c'est quand même en
train de partir et puis là on voit qu'il
reste encore du encore du boulot je
parle même pas des yeux là où on a
priori tout est parti mais la peau à
bien a bien morflé quand même et donc je
me disais comment ça se fait qu'il ya
des traits qui partent mieux que
d'autres et je me suis souvenu que quand
je me suis fait tatouer
il y avait à marc qui avait fait une
moitié du tatouage et julien qui avait
fait l'autre moitié du tatouage donc je
me dis je veux pas savoir qu'ils cessent
m'intéresse pas c'est pas le sujet il y
en a un ou une des deux cas dû appuyer
un peu plus fort que l'autre quand même
voilà ce qui fait que plus d'encre entre
plus profonde et ses plus de pigments à
faire partir voilà c'était ma petite
réflexion du jour écoutez pas mais
promis donc on se retrouve dans deux
mois pour la prochaine séance de l'ader
qui sera la dix neuvième pour le coup un
mémo d'ici là on se retrouve bien sûr
pour plein de vidéos sur les sujets
habituels
en attendant mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]